those stories in just a moment but we
start monday morning with a standoff
breaking news right now at rainbow and
gallon we have bianca holman joining us
there live with what we know so far here
on this early monday morning bianca
hey good morning so we're at rainbow and
gallon on gallon headed westbound you
can see there are still police officers
blocking off this part of gown and it's
because there was a man in an apartment
complex making a suicidal threat so
police have been here on scene and we
actually
heard metro speaking with him over a
loudspeaker overaging him to come out
they're trying to reason with him we're
told the man was in his apartment and
all the roads in the neighborhood
surrounding the complex are closed right
now
we have seen a couple of swat vehicles
and trucks actually leave the scene so
that's why you see this part some of the
cones moved out of the way so it seems
as if again there may be some type of
resolution as we learn more we will keep
you all updated online and on air we're
going to just definitely check in with
metro to see what has come of the
situation since we have seen a couple of
those swat vehicles leave the scene back
to you guys in this